[Music]
good morning everybody thanks for taking
the time to come to this session I
noticed the last year the conference
hopefully you guys had an amazing
conference so today we will talk about
how do customers really accelerate their
API for strategy and leverage Enterprise
and apps and the data which is logged in
there how do you really unlock that
value and bring it bring it to your
customers so I am Paul Bogle I'm part of
the apogee product team within Google
cloud and then I'm also going to be
joined with my co-speaker pratik from
informatica so let's get started today
many many enterprises are at some point
of time in the data journey and it's
really all about taking the awesome
amount of data that they have which
sometimes is locked in silos but unlock
all of them as api's to deliver these
connected experiences that has pretty
much become the hallmark of any
successful digital company as they are
beginning to express more and more of
the capabilities through api's it
becomes very important to take an
outside-in perspective and that's
exactly what we mean by the detail value
chain when we talk to many customers
it's it's pretty obvious they have a lot
of capabilities some of them which are
also enabled at api's but it's not all
about having n number of API the
services it's about how carefully you
curate those api's to deliver the right
kind of experience to the end-user the
app developer plays a very important
role in taking those experiences and
shade them up so that the end user
essentially has the experience of what
they need to see that is what we call as
the outside-in perspective and in our
experience we have seen successful api
programs
really satisfy all the aspects of the
digital value chain Apogee happens to
power successful API program for many
many customers and we are really
thankful for having an opportunity to
serve them as you may see we have
customers across all different verticals
Fortune hundred five hundred thousand
SMBs all kinds of shapes and sizes and
they have come to rely on our
capabilities to be able to run their a
peer programs successfully turns out
Apogee has just the right kind of API
management platform so let's put a few
minutes out here thinking about what's
really required to power a API program
of course there's the secure and
scalable runtime which you need to be
able to power and manage your api
traffic but they're important set of
vertical capabilities which layer on top
of that set an example the mediation
engine gives you all the bells and
whistles such as I need to secure all my
API traffic awesome we have a policy for
that you drop it in and suddenly all the
API traffic is secured using OAuth again
you have some traffic mamonde policies
such as controlling spikes in traffic or
perhaps you want to enforce business
Korra's all those set of capabilities
are provided by the mediation engine as
you start to move up in the layer it
becomes very important for you as a
customer to have the end-to-end
visibility and Tyrel and across the
entire api program whether that means
operational metrics or keeping a track
of how your api program is doing so
developer engagement metrics once we
have api's our developers even building
some apps and driving traffic against
them and last but not the least this
happens to be the most important part of
the platform how do you really engage
with application developers ok how many
application developers in the audience
out here just a quick show of hands ok
so what we have seen is today I'll just
do a very simple analogy if you are
building if we have a mobile ad that
using on your phone and it takes you
more than four seconds for you to
navigate from one screen to the other
chances are you gonna go and download
another app from the App Store right
api's are at that level today if you do
not make it easy for your developers for
the application developers to consume
the API without any friction and if the
API they're not clean and simple to
understand they are going to move to a
different API provider okay so it's very
important to provide a rich catalog of
api's through the developer portal with
complete API documentation so it is very
very easy for them to adopt api's so
Apogee x' APM m and platform offers
exactly that and artificial intelligence
and machine learning is actually built
into the core of the platform many of
our customers have actually used the API
analytics capabilities for a period of
time and they really gotten some good
success out of it especially in keeping
a track of the API program although lot
of those metrics have been more around
trending parts of what really happened
in the last hour or last week what we
are announcing today is the beta of the
apogee api monitoring solution and this
really brings the real-time contextual
API monitoring for api's integrated into
the platform it helps you better manage
your api assays and gives you the
ability to diagnose all your issues in a
much shorter period of time
more importantly we have seen many
customers who express the need that in
order for me to diagnose what's really
happening with my API
I have to correlate many things across a
few different tools such as I want to be
able to see what's happening with my
logs and I want to see what my alerts
are being fired and I really want to be
able to correlate the entire sequence ap
Apogee the API monitoring actually gives
the ability to just within a few clicks
have that context at your fingertips and
we don't want you to take our word for
this one of her key customers bizarre
voice
have been an early adopter of the Apogee
the API monitoring solution and they are
using this to be able to proactively
detect and fix issues even if it happens
to be on their target backends so that
they can manage the customers SLA it's
better we will be turning on this
feature for a lot of our customers over
the next 30 days so really really really
proud to announce this capability now
let's shift back to how do you really
accelerate your API first strategy and
what's really involved in that from our
experience we have seen three high-level
things which take which take the most
pain in terms of trying to become
digital the first one is obviously how
do I easily and securely connect to
cloud services SAS applications and in
many cases on-premise applications as
well
the second piece that becomes really
important once you've done that how do I
easily take those assets turn them into
highly curated api's that can deliver
the right experience and more
importantly do not forget the
application developer you want to ensure
that the application developer has the
right set of tools modular capabilities
so they can reuse those assets and turn
out and turn out a br much faster so for
that let's kind of break down the
anatomy of how do you really access a
cloud service turns out there are a set
of repeatable steps that has to be done
over and over again so let's try and
just walk through them very quickly so
let's say I decide I need to access some
kind of a cloud service well first as an
API developer I have to figure out where
do I store the credentials to that
service could be a service account
it could be just a simple username
password I need a secure mechanism to
persist it secondly once I have that
then I need to go talk to a token
endpoint
passing in those credentials so I can
actually get a token to that service
then I have the same issue that I need
to go manage the token persisted and
also worry about the exploration and
refresh cycles but once I've done that
finally I can do all my cloud service
and although that's a set of things
which you have to do to access service
we feel it's very error-prone if you
have one API developer who's trying to
do that to access a service and suddenly
they need to scale to provide that to
many different services
it just becomes extremely repetitive its
time-consuming it's not easy to have the
application have the API developer why
are those things over in Oregon and more
importantly the random steps tend to
build up over time and causes a lost in
productivity the other thing we
constantly hear is administrators are
not very comfortable letting developers
manage and deal with credentials okay
they want to have the right separation
of concerns they want to be able to have
designated roles who can manage
credentials and more importantly have
the API developers go up and do their
stuff which is go access those api those
services and build some nice experiences
so let's see how we can get around this
how many apogee edge users in the
audience today how many have actually
touched the a page platform okay a few
of them so as you may have come to know
Apogee is a very powerful and
comprehensive full lifecycle API
management platform there are offers you
two big choices you can use a
configuration based option which means
we have 30 different out-of-the-box
policy that you can use to secure to
provide traffic management do some
mediation transformation etc right and
that's great and using some of those
policies you can do those four steps we
just spoke
out right token get your credentials
finally access the service or you can
use some of the out-of-the-box coding
policies that we have and we support
different kinds of languages Java
JavaScript node Python etc however it
still requires you to do those four
steps that we just reviewed manually
today we are introducing the new epi
extensions capability as berra and we
are delighted to have this capability be
available to our customers over the
course of next 30 days now what are the
extensions really bring into the mix it
brings three high-level things it brings
a modular and secure way of connecting
to your cloud services and it gives
developers the ability to use simple
policies which we will show you in a
demo here very quickly to call and
invoke those specific services so as
part of this announcement we are rolling
out eight different GCP extensions
extension GCB services a brand new
extensions management user interface so
org admins can actually go and configure
those extensions and in true apogee
fashion an extension management API so
you can use those api's to be able to
communicate with a platform if you don't
want to use our user interface so here
are the eight new extensions that we are
rolling out today it's available as
berra
so I'm not going to go through the list
but we like you to see a live demo here
very very soon in order for me to
actually show you something useful let's
imagine a use case you're gonna do a
live demo here so in this case how many
of out here ever have to worry about
data loss from an enterprise anyone come
on some of these folks are being shy all
right
data security is a big issue in this
quick example I want to show you how
simple and easy it is for an Apogee API
developer now using a pin
extensions to be able to interact with
the data loss prevention API which is a
service that Google cloud platform
Floyd's okay so in this case let's take
a quick peek at how we would go about
doing that going to switch on to my demo
mode here okay that works awesome
hopefully the demo gods are with us
today and the Wi-Fi works great so one
of the first things you're going to do
out here is very quickly go and look at
the new extensions interface so I'm
logged in to an FPGA Joerg
and I can come to this extensions page
under admin and add any extension so you
can see some of the extensions that we
were talking about out here the cloud
vision API did a loss prevention
firestore stackdriver
up sub so on and so forth the idea is we
are rolling out this extension and we'll
continue to add more down the road but
these are much more purpose-built
towards a PS centric use cases okay so
once I come out here I can just select
that particular extension give it a name
and description and once you do that you
have the extension listed in your
organization so let me just for the
purpose of this demo using existing
extension out here the extension has it
can be deployed across multiple FPGA
edge environments so in this case I have
deployed this thing for test and really
the interface mechanism is super simple
in this case you take the service
account that you have from the Google
cloud platform project you supply the
service credential when you're deploying
this specific extension and once you
save it it will automatically persist
the credential securely and give you a
checksum out here right so separation of
concerns from a governance perspective
the org or the extension admin can come
and do this okay main out here
you will see logs as to when that
specific extension is communicating with
the service in the background great now
once I've done that that's the one time
configuration that I have to do to
enable that extension as an API
developer my job becomes extremely
simple so let's take a look at the DLP
sample in this simple API proxy remember
I still have to go if I'm not eating
extensions go and do those four
different steps we spoke about right but
are using extensions the credential name
and overhead is not my issue so I go out
here than API developer I can add a step
out here click a simple extension caller
policy select any extension that I've
configured in this case DLP and it will
automatically populate the right kind of
action so in this case we have three
actions defined out here which are
obviously reflective of what the data
loss prevention API exhibits which is D
identify with mask with type or redact
the image so I just happen to you the D
identify with mask and you can see I've
already configured this out here I'm
sorry D identify with type specify the
action out here and that's it at this
point in time let's go take this thing
for a quick test
from using postman out here
and I've made some changes in my API
proxy so that I will compare the value
of the header and if it is unsafe I will
not invoke the data loss prevention API
again you can wire this thing in
whichever you want to so in this case
here is the simple request which is
going in
let's hit send I'm going to do that you
should see the data is just passing
through as is not really ideal so now
let's go out here really quickly and
change this to safe mode I'm going to do
that and now send it through you can see
that the data have already been masked
automatically by the data loss
prevention API very simple example of
how you can use a new connector the new
extension mechanism to be able to
leverage any kind of service in a very
very modular way okay
so let's wrap this one up real quick so
we just went through the brand new
extensions capabilities its beta today
will be available for customers as we
start to roll them out in the next 30
days but we are going to be adding a lot
more capabilities we're going to be
building more extensions to existing GCP
services and to other providers and more
importantly we will also be building and
rolling out the same extensions
framework to our customers so you can
build your own custom of private
extensions and use their within the
enterprise finally evolving into a
marketplace of connectors where many of
your partners and customers can actually
contribute their own extensions so they
can be reused within the within the app
universe so real quick what are some of
the key benefits of using the extensions
first-class self service extensibility
built right into the platform you can
connect to any service and more
importantly down the road we can build
and distribute your own service
extensions okay so great
we very quick
looked at how you can accelerate you
know accessing different kind of
services and turning them into quick
api's using extensions but what's
underneath of the API in many cases
turns out enterprises have gobs and gobs
of data and a lot of business processes
which really need to be powered as api's
as we start to talk about this we have
heard from any customers that although
the API mm and platform is really
awesome at curating to the API into some
awesome experiences for the data
experiences that they need to consume
however we really need to be able to
take the data which is sitting locked in
silos leverage the integration processes
which are weaved on top of that and
really bring the entire solution stack
together because the reality is as we
talk to customers we have integration
architects who need to work on working
and building tools business processes
they need to be up level into a pis
so they can power mobile digital and
other connected experiences and that's
exactly what we have done some of you
may have caught up on the recent
announcement we made couple of weeks
back so Apogee has part within some
Erika both collectively breeding
bringing the best to breed and leading
API management solution and the best of
breed iPass solution as per leading
industry analyst together so we give our
customers the ability to actually
leverage these two platforms in unison
be more productive and really accelerate
their apfr strategy with this I would
like to welcome
pratik on the stage pratik take it away
thanks Britt pass thank you everyone
so what I'm going to focus on is what
this partnership looks like where we are
today where we are headed so before we
get started let me actually give you a
quick overview of who we are as
informatica most of you probably know we
have been in this space of enterprise
data management for over 25 years and
since the beginning day one of an
informatics foundation what we have done
is worked with data we have managed the
data we integrate the data we curate the
data you master the data the security
data that's what the informatica
platform as as informatica what we do
today informatica actually has and this
is a good slide that covers over all the
overview of what informatica platform
looks like so as you can see there are
six different categories that we play
into integration integration in the
cloud integration on pram hybrid all of
that big data and big data management
data quality data governance master data
management and price data catalog and
data security that actually that
experience is what we as inform Erika
and Apogee in this case are trying to
nurture and help the customers to unlock
the enterprise data assets that you have
you have in the enterprise and bring it
into the digital and help through your
digital transformation journey the area
that we will be focusing on is
integration platform as-a-service
how many of you know what iPad stands
for integration platform as-a-service is
the new integration platform that are
mostly targeting the cloud integration
and the hybrid integration generally the
the notion there is to bring various
patterns of integration into a managed
environment informatica runs is in
integration platform as a service as a
managed cloud service that supports
almost all and suppose the multi cloud
as well as the hybrid integration
patterns today we process over 2.5
five billion transactions a month we
have over six thousand plus seven
thousand plus customers we have over 100
plus OMS that actually embed our
platform underneath and one of the
significant characteristics that you see
in the top right there is 300% growth
only
on the API volume the way customers are
consuming it and let's let me go and
walk you through as to what that
platform looks like so at the high level
it's very simple this is what the iPass
from a high from an architecture
architecture diagram perspective first
of all it needs to support any
integration pattern integration patterns
are you know are currently as I said
it's converging so there is no big
distinction between an application
integration data integration IOT Big
Data all of that you need to now support
that and the goal here between what
informatic and Apogee is doing is how do
you actually expose those integrations
that you develop in a platform such as
informatica I pass and expose that as an
API and and and what and how you can
unlock that data SS that are behind
running those processes and expose that
for your digital transformation journey
the second thing which is very critical
is the audience is actually expanding
beyond an integration architect or an
API developer today you want to actually
bring the data in the hands of various
different users within your enterprise
your business users your admins and so
on and they should be able to do quickly
data integration data and able to handle
with handle the data as and should be in
their fingertips the third and the key
point is that you need to work with any
sort of data and data is as you all know
could be a structured data which is
locked in an enterprise database or an
application
it could be unstructured data on your
files and log data sources it could be a
streaming data that is coming from
various IOT devices and so on and the
ability to actually work with all sort
of data and expo
that as an API something that we'll be
talking about one of the other big thing
is underlying platform should support
Lord of should be able to handle this
volume of data and that's where our
enterprise unified metadata intelligence
come into play this is an AI and ml
technology that actually powers the
iPass platform and finally the platform
itself has to be very rock-solid
scaleable to actually handle the type of
volume we were talking about today as I
said it's growing a 300% on a
year-over-year in terms of API volume
and we expect that that trend to
continue in fact we are prepared to
actually handle it over thousand percent
as and and that's what we are prepared
to actually handle the key
differentiator of informatica is the
breadth and the depth of connectivity
there is no single data source out there
that we cannot connect you even
mainframe and we know that a lot of
organizations today have data and a
business processes locked in mainframe
how do you actually expose that into
your digital transformation journey and
and when we talk about connectors these
are rich connectors which are very
metadata rich and and can handle various
different transformations on those on
those data sets here a quick example of
data stores on the Big Data side cloud
applications such as workday Mercator
concur if you want to actually reach to
those data sources and turn that into
api's middleware sources such as typical
or any anything that you are talking on
the messaging infrastructure social
applications and so on what we have
announced at what we are working on with
Apogee and this is where we are actually
announcing the the integrated experience
to you all
first and foremost and by the way this
is in beta first and foremost is the
publishing capability so everything that
you have working with on an informatica
environment and I'll give you a quick
demo on that you can actually expose
that into epi genitive lis and with a
point-and-click UI number two is to
consume
if you are an API developer and you want
to actually find out all the various
applications and processes out there
which is powered by informatica how do
you actually extract the value out
directly from your fpga edge environment
so that's the subscriber a subscription
part of it and you can actually auto
discover from within the informatica
tool sets right from very near PG
environment and finally the purpose that
we are working on and we are they
diligently focus on that is how do we
make this rich connectors that we have
over 200 plus native connectors but
thousands of endpoints that we can
connect to how can we actually make that
available in the effigy environment
directly and natively so that you can
actually unlock the power of data and
the applications that are sitting behind
those those applications and make it
available into every G so with that
let's go and look at the first part the
publishing of publishing of informatica
integrations directly into a PG and I'll
go into a demo
so what I'm showing here is a cloud user
interface of informatica intelligent
cloud services for this particular demo
what you are seeing is a integration
architect view and we have provisioned
some of the services of informatica
cloud services to this particular
organization this is a subset of all the
services that informatica cloud services
offer we have the integration hub and we
have the big data services and we have
data masking services and so on which
are not here visible because this org is
power for the integration architect who
is interested in the data integration
and the application integration so I am
going into the application integration
and I'm I'm working on an order
processing application now this is a
typical example where I have I already
have a process inside my enterprise
which actually takes in orders and it is
generating the order information and it
is taking the order through the
lifecycle towards order to cash process
and it is doing the order fulfillment it
doing the order procurement it has to do
all of those things now imagine as then
this enterprise now wants to go digital
and makes this available to your
salespeople who are on the road on the
road and they are spending lot of cycles
right now to actually do all this
manually after they come back from from
there from the field and we want to make
this available to them seamlessly from
within their iPhone or from their phone
or mobile device so what we are trying
to look at this is we are taking an
order processor let's look at the
process here the process is a complex
process it's touching touching number of
different endpoints and it is actually
doing as I said going taking the order
order information and generating an
order and then taking the process
further into the fulfillment cycle I
want to make this available to my API
developer and remember I am playing the
role of an Enterprise Architect so what
it's
this is where the integration the the
one that I talked about of publishing
and service or publishing a process to
the API developer is what I'm going to
show so here as you can see we have a
natively integrated a PG here I'm going
to create this particular and it gives
me a nice visit driven approach to
actually publish this particular process
to my API developer I'm going and
selecting the order process and
selecting the apg org that I want to
deploy to it's walking through these
steps generating auto generating the ID
for the particular process process you
can always rename it I want all the
interfaces to be exposed I have various
different security setup that I can
actually apply here in this case I'm
going to just select the pass through I
can offer a make it available and secure
more as well as in secure mode in this
case I'm going to make it a variable in
both given this we are still testing
this particular process and I don't want
to apply make it available directly in
production I want to make it available
to the API developer in his sandbox so
I'm testing the test environment here
and that's about it at this point the
order processing is it's generating the
proxy and it's making it available to
the API developer to directly invoke it
from within FEG there is an SSO
established between informatica and epi
G so I can directly go into this and get
into the apg interface here and as you
can see that process the business
process is already available and the
endpoint as you can see behind the
scenes and the backend system is talking
to informatica let's see whether this
runs so at this point I'm going to go
into my
postmen client and i'm going to run this
particular
yeah I found it yeah so I sent the
request over to the and you can see the
order information was generated I go
back into the apogee console to see
whether it ran
okay I need to start the trace on and
then I'll invoke on one more one more
request on postman yeah it executed
again
okay and let's see the execution piece
yeah let's look at informatica cloud on
the on the informatica cloud side and
see if that request came true on here
and it shows you the process flow the
execution path this particular request
took
so that was a quick demo of publishing
from the Dean the informatica I pass to
Apogee and we saw how simplest this
whole integration was from all the way
from from actually looking at the
internal business processes and
applications and making that available
to an API developer from there the API
developer can quickly test prototype it
and then make it available and consume
it afford in this particular case for
the mobile application that he was
building to help out his sales team so
we covered this particular flow of
publishing from informatica to the
apogee side what I'll at this point I'll
hand it back to people where he will go
into the other side of the integration
thanks predict so what you saw very
briefly out here was how we have taken
the time to automate the user experience
for an integration architect who's
tasked with building out a lot of these
business processes and within a few
clicks
you can push that as an API proxy within
Apogee right touch down on a lot of the
error-prone redundancy and other steps
that are needed and automates their user
experience all of that can be done from
an Indian America user interface so
let's take a look at the second design
pattern that we have also enabled and
this is the deep integration that Apogee
had done with informatica the other way
around right so in this case in this
scenario really think about you as an
API developer as you're building your
API proxy within Apogee you have a
requirement to be able to reach out to
one or more informatica business and
integration processes right so let's
take a peek at how do we really go about
enabling that user experience without
having to leave the app user interface
in this case we have actually built on
top of our extensions framework and
built a first-class extension to the
informatica integration cloud and in
this design pattern as compared to the
previous
one the final request goes and ends up
with the actual backhand target but in
this case you can see you may have a
existing API which rocks to your
backhand target but you can make
multiple call-outs two different kind of
integration processes so let's take a
peek at this so I think this alright so
let's start out here so I think this
this was working with just a matter of
too many screens open out here the the
order processor 3 was what pratik
vendors through now let's take a quick
peek at how we would go about doing this
thing the other way round so I'm going
to switch orgs here I'm going to G
accelerate for and so again you go to
the admin interface here click on
extensions and I can add an extension
from here so there is this informatica
integration cloud extension that I was
talking about then click on this give it
a name and then save it for the purpose
of this demo I actually already have
configured an extension so the Acme Corp
is the extension which points to that
specific ward within informatica and in
the same style of the extension
interface we have the credentials which
are persisted securely for you within
this informatica integration cloud
extension and then as an API developer
it becomes very easy for me to just call
out that business and integration
process which is telling within X
America by using just a simple policy
step so here is my simple API proxy I
could come out here
click out on the extension caller policy
just in the exact same way that I
connected to the data loss prevention
API
I can select Acme Corp and when I do
that behind the scenes this is actually
invoking the registry API that info
merica has enabled as part of the
product level integration so this is in
real-time introspecting the business
integration processes which are
published in the in America org and
accessible to me using simple design
time constructs so I can search out here
select the one I want and it's as simple
as that for me to invoke that service
I've already configured an API prog the
extension caller policy here and I'm
trying to get lead information back from
this America if I hover out here real
quick within this project structure
within the demo you have the fetch leads
with fields business process very very
simple business process actually goes
and fetches data out of Salesforce and
what I do is I take that process call it
from Apogee do a little bit of data
massaging in terms of the way I want to
return it and then I I call that API so
if I go back out here let's go put this
thing in trace mode the star trace
session I'll jump onto this out here
I'll click on my leads API now you can
see that this lead API URL is different
from the business process that's
available within its America this is the
actual API endpoint that you can use and
share with your mobile apps with any
other kinds of interfaith that you're
trying to make that this thing with this
API also can then be published using all
the Apogee tools into a developer portal
with nice clean generate API
documentation and it can be accessed and
you know available to power many
different kinds of connected experiences
so this really enables let me run this
thing couple times here
so when I make a call to this is
actually going over the wire making a
call to the informatica business process
which is talking to Salesforce getting
the data back we do a quick
transformation and show the data back in
this format right so just imagine how
the integration architects would work
before we had these integrations
available it was possible certainly
however it took a lot of manual work in
many cases we've seen customers who have
completely different integration center
of excellence teams or integration
architects and completely separate API
developer teams right there are lot of
hand-holding and manual passing of
information back and forth it needs to
happen very error-prone not as secure
and more importantly it doesn't bring
out the productivity which is required
to accelerate your API first strategy so
using this kind of integration patterns
the first one again I'll recap which
pratik walked us through is taken and
making the life of an integration
architect super easy by giving you a
couple of clicks so they write from the
name of America UI you can push these
business processes as secure managed API
proxies and they can then be automated
into the API a life cycle so you can
very confidently share that with mobile
apps with any other connected experience
that you're trying to deliver the second
thing that we looked at was without
leaving the Appaji user interface API
developers were interacting with these
kind of very critical processes can
simply use the extensions framework and
the first extension that we had built to
the informatica integration cloud and
integrate with those processes turn them
into API is very very rapidly and the
last announcement that pratik went us
through took us through today was that
we are going to use the exact same
extensions framework which we have used
to enable the nine extensions
that you saw today and take the rich
pallet of connectors that informatica
has to a variety of different kinds of
data sources all the way from SAS
applications big data systems mainframes
and a bunch of different on-premise
sources and turn them into connectors
which customers can use directly from
within the apogee user interface we
believe that tackles our set of use
cases for API developers when they are
not really interested in building a
full-blown business an integration
process but simply have a need to
connect to different kinds of sources
turn that into API is very very quickly
so recapping this today we took you
through a journey of how you can
accelerate your API first strategy
unlock the value in the enterprise apps
and data sources that you have and turn
them into secure manageable and
monetizable api's that will power and
fuel your data transformation
initiatives and your API first strategy
[Music]